hey guys it's Wednesday August fifth I'm
Mary Kish and this is gamespot news
first up in mafia three you're going to
New Orleans back to the year nineteen
sixty eight in a new direction for the
game that's tackling both racism and the
Vietnam War that's heavy for a game
series that doesn't typically handle
topics that sensitive but gamespot's
editor Peter Brown states that mafia
threes premise is simple if you break it
down it's a game that's set in an era
when racial tension was high in America
specifically 1968 when dr. Martin Luther
King was assassinated at the same time
anti-war sentiment was growing the
public wanted to end the struggle in
Vietnam Lincoln who's both black and
veteran war is a character that must
face the harsh realities of both
conflicts while he searches for a place
to call home the story in mafia three
C's Lincoln fighting against the Italian
mob in New Orleans but there's so much
more for more info on mafia 3 check out
GameSpot's video preview where we
discuss the game in more detail we have
learned a ton about Final Fantasy 15 at
Gamescom this year here's a condensed
version of what we know so far the
events of Final Fantasy 15 begin 15
years after the events depicted in the
dawn trailer which was released last
night everything in the trailer was
taken from in-game footage when
referring to the story game director
Tabata said players can expect tragedy
and calamity on an epic scale there's
still some debate on whether or not
airships will be included in the game
they should really make a call on that
soon in regards to the main villain
Tabata said when comparing him to the
other villains in previous Final Fantasy
games that this would be the biggest
baddest villain yet he's going to top
all of them finally we're getting
another demo a playable tech demo is in
the works there's a lot of changes
coming to destiny including a new mercy
rule for the crucible that will end a
match early if one of the sides is
getting crushed it's gonna save you a
lot of time they say
bungie is adding a mercy rule to the
crucible to end unfair matches early if
you find yourself in a wildly unbalanced
match your team is getting crushed or
vice versa the mercy rule come into
effect ending the match and putting your
team back in the matchmaking
additionally matchmaking itself has been
retooled to match your team with teams
of similar skill a bit more often Bungie
has also overhauled the in-game market
for weapons remember the gunsmith that
guy was about as useful as an echo chasm
well now the gun smith is gonna have
newer legendaries for you each and every
week but you'll have to have a high
enough reputation to get them although
you won't be able to boost the power of
current legendaries exotics in the new
legendary weapons can be buffed by
utilizing unwanted exotic and legendary
gear you can sacrifice an item from the
same gear slot to upgrade a different
item making receiving duplicate drops
less disappointing the taken King
launches on September 15th in the spirit
of ti5 triarch announced today that you
can now ban guns in black ops 3
developer treyarch announced a new
multiplayer system called the ban and
protect system it's up on competitive
and private matches and it works by
letting each player pick an item to vote
on to ban or protect before the match
these include items types of perks and
other game affecting features during a
game players band gun sights grenades
and guns themselves they can pick
strategically if they know an opposing
player relies on a certain gun if you
protect an item you'll get access to it
even if another player bans it for
everyone else in competitive games
there's another system called the
specialist draft this introduces a
restriction on the number of specialists
abilities in a single match if one
player chooses a specific ability he or
she is the only one who gets to use that
skill on his or her team during the
match black ops 3 launches on november
six for xbox one 360 ps4 ps3 and pc well
that's all I have for you today if
anyone needs me you can find me in the
chat at the ti5 stream for everything
else news related you can check back
tomorrow at gamespot com
you